hello everyone the nerd medic here and
you are watching
animated biology with urban so in this
video let us talk about the erythrocyte
sedimentation rate or esr
so esr is a test of blood that measures
how quickly the erythrocytes that is the
red blood cells settle at the bottom of
a test tube that contains a blood sample
now if you take some blood in an
anticoagulant added tube and wait for
some time you will see that the rbcs
will settle down at the bottom and the
distance in millimeters of rbc fall in
one hour is a sedimentation rate
now let us understand what biology plays
behind the esr test
now if you take a tube with
anticoagulant at it and put some blood
sample into it and wait for some time
you will see that the plasma will get
separated in the top and there will be
rbc sediments in the bottle
now
this occurs because of something known
as ruler formation now normally rbcs are
present in the blood in a free floating
manner but due to the influence of
certain factors known as the pro
sedimentary factors which are mostly
fibrinogens immunoglobulins rbcs undergo
something known as the ruler formation
which is nothing but a coil stacking
arrangement of the rbcs now this ruler
formation causes sedimentation of the
rbc's over a period of time
now normally the red blood cells settle
down relatively slowly but
if the rate becomes abnormally fast then
that indicates an inflammation that is
going on in the body
now what causes rising esr now rising
esr can be pathological or physiological
pathological causes include malignancies
infections
connective tissue disorders as well as
autoimmune disorders that means mostly
the inflammatory diseases whereas
physiological rise can occur in
old age
female sex
menstruation and pregnancy
not only esr rises sometimes he is a
dips also now this decrease in esr can
be again pathological as well as
physiological pathological causes
include polycythemia sickle cell anemia
low plasma protein as well as
leukocytosis whereas physiological
causes include
young age male sex and dehydration
now
how can we use esr test in the clinics
to treat patients
now doctors
prescribe esr test to determine if you
have an inflammation in your body but as
we all know there can be a lot of
conditions which lead to inflammation in
the body and hence esr cannot
indicate a particular diagnosis
and hence is very non-specific
however esr test tells about the
prognosis that means how a patient is
responding to the treatment that means
suppose
when the patient gets admitted to the
hospital you measure an esr which is
quite high and over the period of
hospital stay the esr
uh levels fall and reach more towards
the normal levels then you can say that
your treatment is working and the
inflammation levels in the body of the
patient is decreasing and that is how
esr tells about the prognosis
and hence there's a popular saying that
goes on in the medical schools esr has
little or no diagnostic value whereas
esr has a prominent prognostic value i
believe you have understood today's
video well if you have understood this
video please go and check out the
facebook page and instagram page of
animated biology with orphan where you
can get high quality notes and flash
cards of sr as well as many other topics
the links are in the description box
below also you can support the channel
so that we can continue to make high
quality educational content for free by
subscribing to us on patreon you can
also use super thanks icon to support
our channel which is in the bottom right
corner of any video and you can
contribute using atm paypal or upi
now if you wish to connect with urban
the social media links of urban are
given in the description box also for
medicine related content i would
recommend you to follow my channel the
not medic all the links of not medic are
given in the description box below until
then bye bye see you in the next one